there's going to be some tough elbows in
that race let's just be very clear it's
going to get rough it's gonna be tough
but I think at the end of the day both
gentlemen understand that the country is
on the line who comes out of that man
Joe Biden might as well go ahead pack
his bags I think it's going to be over
the reuben and joining me today is a
congressman from Florida's 19th District
Congressman Byron Donald welcome to the
Reuben report in the Swamp Man in DC how
did we have to come all the way down
here to do this listen it's work week
you know we finally get back to work so
no Dave it's great to be with you man
thanks for coming up you're working here
in DC this week everyone's here everyone
and their brother they're trying to
figure all this stuff out huh leadership
and Trump's now in and it's messy man uh
it's always messy it's politics I mean
when is the time give me a time when
it's clean yeah right oh that's just not
the case look right now this week
everybody's you know swirling their
bubble trying to figure out who's going
to be in what leadership slot
um are the Republicans at 218 I think we
got that answer late last night early
this morning with Kevin Kiley out in
California
um but you know what we're going to get
through this stuff and then it's going
to be back to business
so what are you thinking about all this
leadership stuff we were at the Senate
building yesterday I talked to a couple
of Congress people everyone's jockeying
for position Tim Scott Florida Tim Scott
Senator is now going to run against
McConnell for the Senate I mean what do
you think is going on here I think it's
good I think it's healthy look Mitch has
been Senate leader for what 10 years 75
years
it's been a long time
um he's also 80 years old you know I
don't really get too caught up in the
age stuff to me it's are you have the
ability the energy to do the job yeah
and as long as you keep that standard
I'm fine with how old you are or frankly
how young you are yeah because I think
sometimes up here on Capitol Hill people
are like oh well you just got here or oh
you're really young you know the Bible
always says don't despise a man because
of his youth so I think it's really
about competence and ability and
execution it's good that Mitch is
getting challenged I know that people
tend to be like oh well how could you
well how could I what every Republican
or every Democrat for that matter that's
up here is because your people sent you
they chose to elect you so if people if
we have to go through that process and
battle for votes at home and earn the
support every time uh from voters then
we come up here we think it's all for
acclimation I think that's wrong and
that's one of the reasons why leadership
frankly on both parties has caused
issues for the people of America so I
think it's healthy you must be feeling
pretty good about leadership in Florida
these days I mean obviously we were
together on on Election night DeSantis
crushes it by 20 points Rubio wins by 15
points something like that like super
majority in the house for Republicans uh
we're doing something right in Florida
is that the blueprint for the rest of
the country right now it is I think take
a step back people need to understand in
Florida a couple things one we have term
limits in our legislature so you don't
have a situation where you have members
who have just been around for a long
long time and then their own power
structure becomes the navigation point
of your state okay our legislation
our legislative seats roll over all the
time that's number one number two
everybody knows Ron DeSantis let's talk
Rick Scott for a moment yeah Rick Scott
before he became Governor Rick Scott
Challenger to Mitch McConnell Rick Scott
he was a donor and he was a businessman
completely upset the apple cart in the
Republican party going back what 2010
2010 2012 was the time when he came in I
think it was 2010. he completely upset
the apple cart the Republican
establishment did not want Rick Scott he
thought that there was a better way he
becomes governor and so then you have
Ron DeSantis he was not the
establishment's choice in Florida he
becomes Governor the disruption is
basically a tea party guy they're the
Liberty caucus I mean it's a freedom
caucus yeah
tea party conservative of tea party
Patriot now he's governor and everybody
says now he's America's governor you
know I said that first by the way yeah
but anyway but he's basically basically
the best governor in the country we all
know this that is because in Florida our
political environment is a meritocracy
that needs to be translated throughout
the United States
do you think other Red State Governors
have the cajones basically to do it I
mean he picks the right fights he's
bringing in the right people I always
tell people you know from the staff I
meet it's like these are good people but
other other Governors they kind of they
still want the media to like them you
know he bans mainstream media from
events like he's fighting in a
completely different way
um I don't know I always told people
back home we have a lot of electives we
don't have a lot of leaders that's just
the truth of the matter yeah
um Carrie Lake
um you know it's unfortunate she didn't
get across the line but she was in that
mold where she was just gonna be like
this is what we're doing
you either like it or you don't but it
is what needs to happen for theirs for
the State of Arizona and I think that
Arizona and my view is going to suffer
because they're not going to have that
type of leadership which is critical in
that state and frankly in all states uh
but are other people capable of Ron
DeSantis type leadership or Donald Trump
type leadership yeah I think so
but you have to have an ability to not
be concerned about what the pundit class
is going to think you have to be willing
to go against the grain sometimes
because you have to look at the facts
look at the data and then present the
best option for people regardless of
what the apparatus is going to say
regardless of what the Press is going to
say so you mentioned Trump now uh you're
a trump guy and you're a DeSantis guy uh
you know it seems like everyone's just
itching for this fight Trump's thrown
out a couple a couple lines on this
thing I keep telling my audience look I
feel like I win either way because if if
DeSantis doesn't run he's our governor
and that's freaking great and then I'll
support Trump if they both run they'll
they'll battle it out and hopefully it
doesn't get too nasty and we get a
better candidate out of it but uh but
what do you think for people because I
think a lot of people like them both
partly for the same reasons partly for
different reasons where does that put
you and what do you think what do you
think they need to do
whoa how about that first and foremost
does it put me in a bad spot oh yeah
yeah because uh look I'm supportive of
both men they both have been tremendous
in the roles that they've played in the
apparatus of our politics Donald Trump
speaks for itself our country and
frankly Republicans learned how to stand
up and do the right thing because of
Donald Trump simply would not have
happened without him absolutely say what
you want but whether it's Mitt Romney
John McCain God Rest his soul George W
bush we had seen the line of let's just
try to do the things that are possible
be leery of the press because they have
more ink in their pen than you have
words in your mouth and all that kind of
other stuff and Donald Trump broke that
mold and said no forget all that those
people don't even know what they're
talking about do the job and then let
the people see the results and they'll
reward you
um and so he has really he is the
Catalyst for the new wave of Republican
um but if you're going to ask me what I
think needs to happen
Donald Trump's speech announcing for the
presidency was exactly where he needs to
be yeah the tone was right pitch perfect
talking about his agenda and talking
about his record because by on a shadow
of a doubt he has the very best record
of anybody in the United States
stay in that lane focus on that he's the
leader in the clubhouse if that's the
Donald Trump you see for the next 16
months he's president of the United
States you can go ahead and book that
right now what would you want to happen
between him and the governor if the
governor gets in I know it's a little
hypothetical stuff but how would you
want it to go down I mean you know both
of them do you want it to all be done
publicly do you want them to kind of you
know have the sit down at Mar-A-Lago and
figure out how to how to work it out I
mean look I would hope they would have a
sit down and figure this thing out
whether that's Mar-A-Lago or the
governor's mansion whatever that place
is uh something tell us
they might want to do it in Orlando
somewhere neutral site or whatever I
don't know but um I would hope that they
will work it out now the reality in
politics is sometimes that's not what
happens yeah so I'm not going to sit
here and tell you what I would hope to
see I'm gonna tell you what I think I
will see yeah it'll it's gonna be rough
I'm just going to tell you it's gonna be
rough uh Governor DeSantis has accorded
himself very very well he's led the
State of Florida biggest win in modern
Florida history nobody thought we would
see election victories like this in
Florida he's the tip of the Spear of
that you got to give the man credit for
what he has accomplished yeah Donald
Trump is looking at this whole thing
like I'm the one that's shown everybody
how to do it you know you know there's
an old Jay-Z line I show you how to do
this son and and that's Donald Trump
yeah and so I think that that's going to
be there's going to be some tough elbows
in that race let's just be very clear
it's gonna get rough it's gonna be tough
um but I think at the end of the day
both gentlemen understand that the
country is on the line who comes out of
that man Joe Biden might as well go
ahead pack his bags I think it's going
to be over yeah well Amen to that and
for the record unless you're unless you
know something I don't know we don't
even know if this had this wants to run
I mean it's just it's just as simple as
that like the guy loves Florida that's
what people keep saying it's like is he
going to run he loves this state look I
want to piggyback off what you just said
I don't think a decision's been made on
this as much as the pundit class is
throwing it out there and they keep
asking the questions because it's click
bait and that's what people people want
to watch and see I would rather the
media actually focus on this FTX debacle
because that's some there's some real
stuff going on that has to be uncovered
but I digress
he has not made a decision
maybe he's made it in his mind but
nothing's really coming out like
signaling this here we go here we go
here we go I think we gotta like pump
the brakes
Donald Trump has now come out he's
announced yeah let Ron DeSantis take the
time whatever that time might be to
decide what he's going to do and then
we're going to have plenty of time for
the fireworks trust me right it's very
early anyway let me ask you something
else just about being here in DC and
being somewhat new in Congress and that
technically you don't look exactly like
what a generic Congressman looks like
you're you're black is that that's what
my guys told me right before he was
that's what they said we were trying to
figure it out my mama said it came out
the room so yeah
um how does it feel to be in this you
know like when you're doing your thing
in Florida and it's just kind of working
and then you come to a place like this
where it's all about the jockeying and
the media and everything else like do
you like being here when you're in DC
doing your thing sometimes like it's
just to be straight with you man this
place is surreal like it's still surreal
that I'm here that I'm doing this yeah I
told my colleagues you know you know
after this conference chair thing they
were like man you know it didn't work
out how do you feel and I'm like are you
kidding me if you look at my life going
up from Brooklyn New York all the
struggles I've been through
to being in the room doing this yeah man
I'm playing with house money man so that
part is so static for me yeah
um now just keeping it real because this
is what I do the petty backstabbing
stuff in DC man I don't like that kind
of stuff yeah like I'm a man if you feel
a certain way say it yeah I will respect
you if you do I don't do all the back
talk backstabbing stuff I don't like
that stuff
I'm very diplomatic and I'm a genuine
person I'm very nice you know I respect
everybody because I want people to
respect me I'm here about business I'm
here to fight for the country I'm here
to win for the country but all these
little petty games Dave I'm not that guy
yeah that is not me
um I'm still a kid from Brooklyn New
York I'm a kid from the streets who you
know has matured through life built a
career engaged in politics I just wanna
Let's do let's do business and let's go
home we don't we're not always going to
like each other we're not always going
to greeted with each other and that's
fine yeah but let's do business let's
make sure it gets done for the people
all the petty stuff I'm not a big fan of
that two guys born in Brooklyn fighting
in the Free State of Florida pretty cool
I got all right two more for you and
then we'll let you go so uh just talk to
me real quick about what's going on with
the the hurricane recovery because as I
told people you you are the congressman
for I mean you got hit it is your that
is your home area right there what's the
latest uh it's gonna be tough sledding
on our beaches our beaches were hit
really really hard
um that's what's going to take two years
in my opinion to rebuild now I want to
caution everybody most of Southwest
Florida is back up and running you know
our restaurants are open our businesses
are open hotels airbnbs you know I think
some of the
the boat rentals and stuff you can still
probably get your boats and get out to
certain places some of the places are
still going to have to be repaired but
Southwest Florida is open people are
flying in and out right now as we speak
but our Barrier Islands our beaches
they're going to take some time to
recover in Fort Myers Beach specifically
in Sanibel in Bonita Beach uh the beach
in Naples you know they're gonna we're
gonna redo some stuff but we'll be back
on track it's going to be fine it's just
gonna take uh time and some patience now
I think we have the leadership to get
that done obviously Governor DeSantis at
the head of that has been phenomenal our
local leadership has done a tremendous
job
um FEMA SBA we've been working in
concert with them everybody's pulling
forward it's just going to take time to
get it back were there any major
screw-ups with this thing because it
felt like it was just clear as
disastrous as it was that it was just
kind of clean and obviously the governor
gets a lot of credit for that but FEMA
you know there are federal agencies that
came in and helped too well listen first
of all in terms of screw-ups the way the
Press like to talk about it because they
were waiting they wanted something
that's yeah they do this stuff all the
time the reality is that storm and I
remember I was at the National Hurricane
Center because I was here in DC when the
storm made landform and the modelers
were telling me directly it was tough to
predict the track on this storm because
it kept they call it jogging like it
kept moving from here to there to here
to there
and it just kept jogging I think it was
Tuesday late Monday into Tuesday before
that storm hit we had people who
evacuated from Tampa Bay in the Fort
Myers and they were shocked when they
basically were in the epicenter of the
storm because all the modeling has
showed Tampa Bay Sarasota County and so
that's kind of what happened it was
tough but I think in terms of response
in terms of preparedness and response
top notch all right I got one more for
you
what do you want to do after uh be in
Congressman for a couple of terms
we have a governor who might move on to
some other things there's all sorts of
interesting opportunities and also a
Republican party that's obviously in
flux right now and and needs some new
voices
what do you think about that when I left
this when I left the state household my
colleagues said um would you ever come
back and I said I'm only coming back one
way
all right I like it I like it
good to see you man good to see you all
right if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell